[Music]
from more oh so Stanley cameos it's not
fair
you're gonna make me cry we haven't even
started yet Marvel is taking it back to
the first a venture no not that one this
Avenger before are the new ones like an
man
well not that a man before Black Panther
at least well after two chocolate was
Black Panther but before T'Challa right
look I don't know it's it's the 90s okay
chief she's the nineties one Captain
Marvel journey to Halle and meet Captain
Marvel a girl with the power of
spaceship she's a snarky flying soldier
with amnesia on a quest to recover her
true identity a snarky flying soldier
without amnesia just don't tell her how
to feel into motion isn't a single
dangerous war warrior and emotion you
struggle with your emotions do not let
your emotions override your judgment and
you keep your emotions in check long
enough to take me on because this hot
rod pilot likes to keep it in neutral
we'll get to the bottom of this fears
together okay
you okay
mmm-hmm dreams again
Carroll calm down you're getting too
emotional okay bring the kree's not
alone like every Marvel hero she needs
someone to smirk add like jaan raghav o
matic yoda maria rambo her marvel issued
black friend Annette Bening in a dual
role as a sign as we don't really get to
know and a computer we don't really
understand the dog from the thing in cat
form and stealing the show a facially D
aged Nick Fury an effect that will
completely fool the eye until you notice
him run fight or use a keyboard Oh
grandpa's in the computer building
superhero teams again you've waited
years for Marvel to introduce the
scrawls thrill with the possibility that
they'll be the next big bad after Thanos
because they could be anyone from
Captain America to cute cuddly family
mom
wait the scrolls are nice how do you not
make ben mendelsohn evil then Mendelson
is always evil we are so not getting
Secret Invasion are you ready for a plot
buster it won't take AltaVista to find
one
because Captain Marvel is a street
fighter too and she's onto your Game Boy
so back off trolls and go back to the
mall rats her powers don't need to be
nerve because she's not melancholy about
rocking the boat in the bush Leonard
Cohen holy schnikeys these 90s
references are his forces the movies
Nine Inch Nails radioshack
alright I'm done so get ready for a film
that's disappointing
if it's the meet and an infinity war
sandwich a solid watch if it's up
against the other Marvel origin stories
and Citizen Kane Kane compared to female
and superhero movies not named Wonder
Woman look out boys at this rate lady
heroes will take over at the theater
never starring the Katniss Miss Marvel
Nick furry scroll and clones law in
orbit as Kree you
Blue Man true the Garfield your aunt
still has stuck in her car windshield
Maria Rambo cut Skynet Benning equi Rhea
at NIOSH who paid DLC and the
screenwriter of what lies beneath just a
fun fact I know instead of my daughter's
birthday where burn harm last time I
trusted someone I lost an eye I'm
trusting you not to eat me what's better
than an honest game trailer - honest
game trailers thanks to e3 we're
blasting you in the face with a double
barrel of honesty click one of them now
or my mom will cancel my xbox lies put
the bunny back in the box
Khwaja ties me captain